I believe this is a great opportunity
for us to bring our own projects,
and to share these and also compare these
with others involved in the Laboratory
– all of whom are very qualified.
This process will help guide my own work
in a more detailed and precise way.
Dramaturgy is a concept
which can not be defined just in one way.
I would say it's quite an open concept
that you can orientate and build
in different ways.
We will give a clearer idea
about what a dramaturg can do
and also, maybe, I hope
that we also get some knowledge
about composition and design structures
of movement, and maybe choreography.
It has been inspiring to see the multiple ways
in which people build in dramaturgy
and to be able to pick on the way
they are building their performances,
their artistic content.
It's important that
the participants understand also
the questions to do to a dramaturg.
I mean, I have this idea,
how I can spend all my energy
to express my idea,
so working with tension,
with time, with movements,
with all the elements of a choreography.
I saw they were very interested about
acoustic [audio] description,
I saw a very theoretical part
about dramaturgy,
I saw different kinds of things,
and all those gave me the inspiration
to start looking also by myself a lot of things.
I can say that I have more knowledge
about what is happening.